[Music]
digital technologies have greatly
changed our daily life
therefore Europe wants to make sure that
the digital transformation works for all
its citizens the opportunities are many
equal access to education and healthcare
ease of transport safer working
conditions and a sustainable planet our
goal is to build on European values and
project them onto the international
stage however we can only achieve these
with technology that works for the
people a competitive digital economy for
business and empowered citizens our goal
is that Europe ensures technological
sovereignty digital transformation built
with and for the people this will be the
European way
[Music]